-When did you realize that
you have perfect pitch?
-Right.
-Do you know this?
Do you know what that is?
Perfect pitch?
Less than 1% of us have
this talent, but basically --
-I think you might have it.
The Roots told me you might
low-key have it.
-Oh, I don't think I have it.
-It means you can like, hear,
like, any note.
Like, if I were to tell you to
play an F sharp, it would be --
[ Vocalizes note ]
-Wow.
-Or a G.
[ Vocalizes note ]
Or C sharp.
-What if I gave you,
like, B flat?
-[ Vocalizes note ]
-Is that right?
-So, it's almost like I
memorized the notes in my head,
and I could do it from
when I was like four years old.
It's like a weird --
It's a very odd thing.
-That's unbelievable.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, it definitely affects me
socially sometimes
because I was in a hotel room
the other night,
and usually when you hear
car horns and fire alarms,
they're at minor
second intervals, like...
[ Vocalizes notes ]
Like, "Jaws" is like, "Get out
of the water," Jaws.
[ Vocalizes "Jaws" theme ]
And that's what
a fire alarm is sometimes,
and it's two notes rubbing
against each other,
and it tells you to get the hell
out the building,
and I was on the 11th floor,
and I wasn't getting
out of the building.
I was, like, rearranging notes
in my my mind,
and I was like,
"What if it was like..."
[ Vocalizes notes ]
Like, there was one time --
-You're harmonizing with
the alarm?
-I'm harmonizing with the alarm.
I let my entire school out early
one time
because there was a digital bell
that went like this.
Rumson-Fair Haven Regional
High School.
I got suspended for this.
It went...
[ Mimics bell ]
So, I was -- I wanted --
It was almost summer break,
and I went into the middle of
the hall and went into
a very reverberant part of
the school and just went...
[ Mimics bell ]
I let the entire school out
early.
-No way!
That's awesome!
-I got suspended for that.
That was not good.